[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer passt gut
auf denn was der euch heute erzählen
wird euch nicht unbeeindruckt lassen für
den Anfang solltet ihr folgende Tatsache
im Hintergrund behalten zwei Drittel der
Weltbevölkerung leben in Ländern in
denen die Geburtenrate nicht einmal
Ersatzrate von 2,1 Geburten pro Frau
entspricht die für den Erhalt einer
stabilen Bevölkerung auf lange Sicht
notwendig ist tatsächlich hat es in der
entwickelten Welt nur Israel geschafft
eine Geburtenrate zu erreichen die über
diesen Wert liegt und das hat natürlich
Konsequenzen schaut es euch an
weltbevölkerungswachstum erreicht
niedrigste Rate seit 1950 tatsächlich
führten der Anstieg der Sterblichkeit
der Rückgang der Geburtenzahl und eine
geringere Nettozuwanderung aufgrund der
Pandemie dazu dass die Bevölkerung
Europas in den Jahren 2020 und 21 und
mehr als 2 Millionen Menschen
[Musik]
an diesem Trend müssen wir uns wohl
gewöhnen denn er wird in diesem
Jahrhundert in Europa und auch in vielen
anderen Regionen auf der Welt anhalten
Japans Bevölkerung schimpft
beispielsweise bereits als 2010
Südkoreas Bevölkerung beginnt seit 2020
ebenfalls schrumpfen und Chinas
Bevölkerung wird voraussichtlich in
diesem oder spätestens im nächsten Jahr
das gleiche tun es gibt sogar Experten
die vermuten dass diese Rückgang bereits
begonnen hat
tatsächlich wird erwartet dass Chinas
Bevölkerung bis zum Mitte des
Jahrhunderts um 12 Millionen Menschen
pro Jahr schrumpfen wird in vielen
Teilen der Welt wird es immer weniger
junge Menschen und viel mehr ältere
Menschen geben und ich denke dass ich
99% der Population nicht im geringsten
vorstellen können was das für eine
Gesellschaft und ihre Wirtschaft
bedeutet wenn die Alterspyramide Kopf
steht klar das ganze ist durchaus
verständlich denn niemand von uns hat so
einen Zustand jemals erlebt und niemand
weiß ob das überhaupt irgendwie
einigermaßen erträglich funktionieren
kann wir können heute also nur ahnen und
Bangen wie sich der Wohlstand das Leben
der Alltag und ich Versorgungslage in
all diesen heute noch leistungsfähigen
Ländern entwickelt werden sobald sie in
die totale altersstarke fallen aber
wartet mal einen Moment denn die
Überalterung des einen Teils der Welt
ist nur die eine Seite der ganzen
Medaille
wir sind uns dessen vielleicht nicht
täglich bewusst aber Afrika der
Kontinent der immer in Vergessenheit
geraten war erlebt wie manche meinen den
größten demografischen Aufschwung in der
Geschichte der Menschheit dieses
Wachstum das ich keineswegs zu
verlangsamen scheint ist in den letzten
Jahrzehnten sprunghaft angestiegen und
verspricht einen Wendepunkt in der
Geschichte der Menschheit zu markieren
dies ist Afrikas jahrhundert Cyril Drama
fuser Präsident Südafrikas und nehmt
euch acht denn das ist erst der Anfang
die Veränderung von der wir euch heute
erzählen werden geht viel weiter als sie
es je für möglich gehalten hättet sie
wird vor allem auch Europa betreffen in
Guten wie im Schlechten und sich
vollzieht sich rasend schnell also lasst
uns keine Zeit verblendbar und sofort
loslegen
[Musik]
wie Afrika die Welt verändern wird
im Jahr 2018 eröffnete der ukandische
Präsident musste wenig seinen Rede zur
Lage der Nation mit der Aussage dass die
Bevölkerung 14 Millionen Menschen im
Jahr 1986 auch über 40 Millionen
angestiegen sein das entspricht einem
jährlichen Bevölkerungswachstum von mehr
als 3,5% während der Durchschnitt in den
20 Jahren vor seiner langen Amtszeit als
Präsident bei 2,5% lag das hat dazu
geführt das Uganda eine der jüngsten
Populationen der Welt hat das
Durchschnittsalter liegt bei nur 17
Jahren und um das noch zu verdeutlichen
sind drei Viertel der Uganda unter 30
Jahre alt eine riesige Reserve bereit
viele viele weitere Kinder zu bekommen
wenn liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer wir
reden hier über ein Land in dem Frauen
im Durchschnitt fünf Kinder bekommen das
liegt unter anderem daran dass die
Bevölkerung sehr jung ist und sehr früh
mit dem Kinderkriegen beginnt daran hat
sich übrigens auch trotz der stark
gesunkenen Kindersterblichkeitsrate
nichts geändert das Ergebnis die
Bevölkerung Ugandas wächst mit einer
Rate von fast 40% rote Karte
und das ist noch nicht alles in einer
weiteren im Fernsehen übertragenen Rede
wurde Präsident musste veni noch viel
deutlicher
einige sagen es gäbe eine
Überbevölkerung in Afrika aber das
stimmt nicht Afrika leidet unter einer
starken unterbevölkerung aber wir sind
jetzt dabei das Problem zu lösen juveri
musste wenig Präsident Ugandas denn
obwohl Afrikas Fläche der dreifachen
Größe Europas entspricht und es der
zweitgrößte Kontinent der Welt ist weiß
seit 1950 nur für ein Fünftel des
weltweiten Bevölkerungswachstums
verantwortlich aber jetzt scheint sich
alles vollständig zu ändern denn die
hohen Geburtenraten werden von einer
großen Mehrheit der Gesellschaft
befürwortet Kultur Religion und sogar
die Politik unterstützen das enorme
Bevölkerungswachstum und glaubt mir es
ist wirklich enorm sobald ihr das wahre
Ausmaß erkannt habt wird es euch die
Sprache verschlagen die Welt wie ihr sie
kennt wird sich in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten komplett verändern hört euch
dazu einfach mal folgendes an
im Jahr 1914 wurde die Bevölkerung
Afrikas auf nur 124 Millionen Menschen
geschätzt heute gibt es bereits 1,34
Milliarden Afrikaner während sich die
Bevölkerung Asiens um das drei bis
vierfache vergrößert hat hat sich die
afrikanische Bevölkerung um das 11-fache
vergrößert zum Vergleich während der
industriellen Revolution hat sich die
Bevölkerung Europas kaum verdoppelt wir
sprechen also von einem noch nie da
gewesenen Wachstum in der gesamten
Menschheitsgeschichte und vor allem ist
das erst der Anfang Schätzungen der
Vereinten Nationen zufolge wird die
Bevölkerung Afrikas bis 2050 auf über
2,4 Milliarden Menschen anwachsen mit
anderen Worten während 1980 einer von
zehn Menschen auf der weltafrikaner war
wird in der Mitte dieses Jahrhunderts
also nur in wenigen Jahrzehnten etwa
jeder vierte Mensch auf der Erde auf
diesen Kontinent geboren sein
um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
was das eigentlich bedeutet im Jahr 1950
umfassen die gesamte Weltbevölkerung
lediglich 2,5 Milliarden Menschen und
nur 100 Jahre später werden alleine auf
dem afrikanischen Kontinent so viele
Menschen leben Afrika ist bereits heute
mit Abstand der haupttreiber des
weltweiten Bevölkerungswachstums was ich
gut an den Wachstumsraten einzelne
afrikanischer Länder erkennen lässt
weltweit haben derzeit zum Beispiel nur
acht Länder eine
bevölkerungswachstumsrate von mehr als
3%, was ungefähr eine Verdoppelung der
Bevölkerung alle 20 bis 24 Jahre
entspricht ja und alle acht dieser
Länder befinden sich in Afrika außerdem
haben derzeit nur elf Länder eine
Geburtenrate von fünf oder mehr Kindern
auch sie liegen alle in Afrika von den
20 Ländern weltweit deren Bevölkerung
bis 2050 am stärksten wachsen wird
liegen alleine 12 auf diesem Kontinent
mit anderen Worten gewöhnt euch besser
daran dass die Welt wie ihr sie kennt
zukünftig mehr und mehr von dieser
Region auf verschiedenste Weisen
beeinflusst werden wird
[Musik]
und das ist noch nicht alles aktuell
sieht es so aus als ob das Wachstum der
afrikanischen Bevölkerung weiter
anhalten wird voraussichtlich wird
Afrika sogar zum Ende des Jahrhunderts
der einzige Kontinent auf der Welt
seiner überhaupt noch eine relevante
Wachstumsrate aufweist selbst Indien
erreicht im Jahr 2021 nur noch eine
Fertilitätsrate von zwei Kindern pro
Frau und befindet sich entgegen der
langläufigen Meinung also mittlerweile
unter der Ersatzrate von 2,1 Kindern
Tendenz bald und was denkt ihr auf
welchen Kontinent werden 38 der 40
Länder mit dem niedrigsten medialen
Alter der Welt liegen ihr könnt es euch
wahrscheinlich bereits denken viele
Experten darunter auch die Vereinten
Nationen weisen darauf hin dass die
Bevölkerung Afrikas bis zum Ende des
Jahrhunderts etwa 40% der gesamten
Weltbevölkerung ausmachen wird das
bedeutet vier von zehn Menschen auf der
Welt werden dann Afrikaner sein das
entspricht einer Bevölkerung von mehr
als 4 Milliarden Menschen das heißt
viermal so viel wie China dann haben
wird und exakt so viel wie 1975 auf der
ganzen Welt gelebt haben falls diese
Prognose eintrifft bedeutet es dass
zwischen 2020 und 2100 mehr als 90
Prozent des weltweiten
Bevölkerungswachstums auf Afrika
entfallen wird könnt ihr euch eine Welt
vorstellen in der die Hälfte aller
jungen Menschen und was die Held der
gesamten erwerbsfähigen Bevölkerung aus
Afrika stammt die gesamten globalen
Verhältnisse würden sich dadurch
vollkommen verändern während die
Gesellschaften der heutigen
Industrieländer weiter verkreisen und
erstarren würden sich im Gegensatz dazu
die jungen und dynamischen afrikanischen
Gesellschaften zum dreh- und Angelpunkt
der Welt entwickeln und das würde alles
verändern natürlich ist es nicht
dasselbe einfach über das Jahr 2100
anstelle von 2050 zu sprechen umso
länger der Zeitraum der Prognose ist
desto schwieriger wird es eine genaue
Vorhersage zu treffen trotzdem lässt
sich aber mit einer sehr hohen
Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen dass zum Ende
des Jahrhunderts mindestens einer von
drei Menschen auf der Welt aus Afrika
sein wird
[Musik]
schauen wir uns zum Beispiel den Fall
Niger an es ist eines der ärmsten Länder
der Welt und übrigens einer der
Verbündeten des Westens im Kampf gegen
die Dschihadisten in der Sahelzone über
die haben wir übrigens mal ein sehr
interessantes Video gemacht aber zurück
zum Niger in diesem Land bekommen die
Frauen im Durchschnitt mehr als 7 Kinder
was übrigens in den letzten Jahren
weiter zugenommen hat das
Durchschnittsalter liegt daher bei nur
14,5 Jahren das bedeutet 50% der Bürger
des westafrikanischen Nigers sind jünger
als 14,5 Jahre wir sprechen hier
praktisch von einem gigantischen
Kindergarten
in nur 100 Jahren zwischen 1950 und 2050
wird sich die Bevölkerung dieses Landes
um das 25-fache vergrößert haben von 2,5
Millionen auf März 60 Millionen
Einwohner und ihr werdet euch spätestens
an dieser Stelle sicherlich fragen hat
der ukantische Präsident musste veni
eigentlich recht mit seiner These von
der unterbevölkerung Afrikas es ist doch
immer Afrika seit total überbevölkert
und dies da die Hauptursache für die
dortigen Not ist es überhaupt möglich
dass so viele Menschen in Afrika leben
können
nun ja das ist es schaut euch einmal
dazu die Größe Afrikas an obwohl sich
die Bevölkerung seit 1950 war sechsfacht
hat ist Afrika im Wesentlichen ein
leerer Kontinent geblieben die
Bevölkerungsdichte liegt bei etwa 44
Menschen pro Quadratkilometer weniger
als ein Drittel der Bevölkerungsdichte
Chinas selbst wenn wir die Wüstenflächen
die immerhin ein Drittel des Kontinents
ausmachen abziehen kommen wir auf nur 66
Menschen pro Quadratkilometer allerdings
legen wir auch in Wüstenstaaten wie
Saudi-Arabien Dutzende von Millionen
Menschen wenn wir zum Beispiel die
kleinen Inselstaaten ausschließen haben
nur fünf Länder rohrender Burundi Uganda
Nigeria und Malawi eine
Bevölkerungsdichte von 200 oder mehr
Menschen pro Quadratkilometer zum
Vergleich Deutschland liegt bei 230
Südkorea bei über 500 und Bangladesch
war über 1.200 gut in Bangladesch
stapeln sich die Leute bereits aber in
Afrika gibt es noch jede Menge Platz die
Gründe für die Probleme Afrikas in der
Vergangenheit wie z.B hungerstöte liegen
in ungeeigneten Sozialstrukturen in
betroffenen Ländern um in der
Bevölkerung die notwendige Produktivität
für ihre Selbstversorgung herzustellen
und die vorhandenen ressourcengerecht zu
verteilen wenn Afrika also diese
Faktoren in den Griff bekäme könnte es
durchaus eine solche gigantische
Population ernähren die Frage ist daher
wie weit die afrikanischen
Gesellschaften in diesen
Modernisierungsprozess eigentlich
fortgeschritten sind nun ja
möglicherweise eben weiter als viele
denken aber eben auch anders als es für
die gesamte Welt erstrebenswert wäre
aber Moment mal sind diese Prognosen
dann eigentlich wirklich zuverlässig
wenn sich Afrika modernisiert durchläuft
ist dann nicht auch den sogenannten
demografischen Wandel oder haben die
Experten das bisher noch nicht
berücksichtigt und vielleicht die
wichtigste Frage von allen was genau
wird dieses enorme Wachstum diese
gewaltige demografische Revolution für
den Rest der Welt bedeuten lasst uns das
alles jetzt herausfinden
die Anomalie des vergessenen Kontinents
Europa Lateinamerika Asien jedes Mal
wenn sich eine Gesellschaft modernisiert
und wirtschaftlich entwickelt hat fand
das statt was wir als demografischen
Wandel bezeichnen zunächst sind die
Sterblichkeitsrate bei einer anhaltend
hohen Geburtenrate was zu einem Anstieg
des Bevölkerungswachstums führt dann
aber beginnt etwas zeitversetzt die
Geburtenrate ebenfalls zu senken und das
Bevölkerungswachstum verlangsamt das ist
praktisch ganz zum Stillstand kommt und
aufgrund der zunehmenden Alterung der
Bevölkerung sogar negativ wird das ist
zumindest die Theorie und entspricht der
Erfahrung wird bisher in der Welt
gemacht haben in Afrika sehen die Dinge
aber ganz anders aus obwohl die
Sterblichkeitsrate stark gesunken und
die Lebenserwartung der Bevölkerung
stattgestiegen ist sinken die
Geburtenraten in Afrika ungewöhnlich
langsam
in den afrikanischen Ländern südlich des
Sahara ist die Geburtenrate in den
letzten 20 Jahren lediglich von 6,5
Geburten pro Frau auf 5,4 gesunken und
in einigen Ländern ist die sogar wieder
gestiegen Rücklicht war
in einigen Ländern Afrikas ist die
Fertilität noch nicht zurückgegangen und
das wird sich in den kommenden Jahren
wohl auch nicht ändern in vielen anderen
Ländern waren die Veränderungen begrenzt
und zögerlich während einige Länder die
in ihrem fabilitätswandeln weit
fortgeschritten waren unerwartete Wege
mit einer langsameren und stagnierenden
fertilitätsentwicklung eingeschlagen
haben ein weiteres Beispiel ist Ägypten
ein Land das scheinbar den
demografischen Wandel vollendet hatte
die Geburtenrate Sankt bis zum Jahr 2008
auf drei Kinder ist dann jedoch wieder
auf aktuell 3,2 gestiegen diese
Trendwende fahren dass du sogar die UN
dazu die Bevölkerungsprognose bis 2050
auf 160 Millionen Einwohner zu erhöhen
und obwohl der demografische Wandel
sowohl im nördlichen als auch im
südlichen Afrika relativ weit
fortgeschritten ist liegen die
Geburtenraten dort immer noch deutlich
über denen der übrigen Welt sie liegen
praktisch bei mehr als drei Kindern pro
Frau aber wartet einen Moment denn was
sich in der Mitte dieses Kontinents
abspielt das ist wirklich monumental was
um alles in der Welt ist also in Afrika
los
[Musik]
nun die Wahrheit ist das hier viele
Faktoren zusammen spielen einige jedoch
deutlich hervorstechen fakt ist dass die
Kultur die Regierungen und die Religion
dort so stark wie nirgendwo sonst auf
der Welt das Bevölkerungswachstum
unterstützen die große Trendumkehr beim
Rückgang der katalitätsraten die um das
Jahr 2000 herum stattfand ist zu einem
großen Teil auf davor liegende
Rückschläge bei der Emanzipation der
weiblichen Bevölkerung vor allem im
Bildungsbereich zurückzuführen denn die
überall auf der Welt bekommen auch in
Afrika gebildete Frauen weniger Kinder
und je mehr Frauen mit schlechter
Bildung es gibt desto kinderreiche sind
die Familien dieses Phänomen passt auch
zu den Unterbrechungen in den Kohorten
Trends beim Bildungsabschluss von Frauen
nach dem wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Turbulenzen die sich in
diesen Ländern nach der erlangen ihrer
Unabhängigkeit ergaben und das so
führten dass der Anteil der schlicht
gebildeten Frauen im gebärfigen Alter in
der 90er Jahren Anfang der 2000er Jahre
höher war als es sonst der Fall gewesen
wäre aus Umfragen wissen wir dass
afrikanische Familien deswegen in der
Regel viele Kinder haben wollen das in
sehr früh mit dem Kinderkriegen beginnen
und dass sie wenig Verhütungsmittel
benutzen in Niger zum Beispiel Träumen
Frauen davon 9 bis 10 Kinder zu haben
und Männer nicht weniger als 13 in den
elf Ländern mit den höchsten
Bevölkerungswachstum des Kontinents
findet die erste Geburt bereits im
Jugendalter statt und in Angola liegt
die Geburtenrate trotz der Tatsache dass
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in
städtischen Gebieten leben und ein
relativ hohes BIP pro Kopf hat immer
noch bei sechs Kindern aber okay da wird
diesen und alles Wissen stellt sich
immer noch die Frage welche globalen
Veränderungen wird die afrikanische
Bevölkerungsexplosion nach sich ziehen
passt gut auf
[Musik]
die neue Epoche
die Welt verändert sich so schnell das
wir vielleicht gar nicht in der Lage
sind die Veränderungen in ihrem vollen
Umfang zu erkennen wusstet ihr zum
Beispiel dass die Volkswirtschaften
Asiens im Jahr 2020 zum ersten Mal seit
dem 19 Jahrhundert wieder größer waren
als die der restlichen Welt
zusammengenommen nun ja so ist es und
gleichzeitig sind die wohlhaberen Länder
vor allem die Länder Europas nicht nur
mit dem demografischen Rückgang
konfrontiert sondern zusätzlich auch mit
den gesellschaftlichen Herausforderungen
einer zunehmend alternden Bevölkerung so
wäre zum Beispiel erwartet dass die
Bevölkerung der Europäischen Union im
Jahr 2016 kaum 5% der Weltbevölkerung
ausmachen wird und nicht nur das 30
Prozent der gesamten europäischen
Bevölkerung werden dann voraussichtlich
über 65 Jahre alt sein mit anderen
Worten die Welt ist in den letzten
Jahren immer asiatischer geworden und in
Zukunft wird sich vor allem auch
afrikanischer
stellt euch einen Kontinent vor dem Jahr
2050 die gleiche Bevölkerungszahl haben
wird wie Indien in China zusammen stellt
euch einen Kontinent vor der einem
wachsende Mittelschicht und eine rasante
Urbanisierung aufweist und ich nach 2050
die jüngste Bevölkerung der Welt haben
wird denkt an Afrika akinumi arestina
Präsident der Afrikanischen
Entwicklungsbank und wenn uns die
Geschichte eine Sache lehrt dann ist es
das junge und wachsende Bevölkerung
früher oder später zu wachsenden
wirtschaftlichen und politischen
Einfluss und zu Expansionsdrang führen
das bringt natürlich auch enorme
Herausforderungen mit sich derzeit
erreichen jedes Jahr 30 Millionen
Afrikaner das 15 Lebensjahr ein alter
das sind dieser Region als
Eintrittsalter in das Arbeitsleben gilt
in den kommenden Jahren und Jahrzehnten
wird Afrika also vor der Herausforderung
stehen enorme Mengen an Arbeitsplätzen
schaffen zu müssen
und dies wirkt jede Menge sozialen
Sprengstoff gemäß der kriegsindextheorie
des deutschen soziologieprofessors una
Heinsohn kommt es bei einem starken
Ungleichgewicht zwischen Karriere
Suchenden jungen Männern und verfügbaren
gesellschaftlichen Positionen den
sogenannten use Ball also
jugendüberschuss notwendigerweise zu
Konflikten oder einem sehr hohen
Migrationsdruck
dieses Konfliktpotenzial wird natürlich
durch die Faktoren Bildungsmangel und
diktatorische Herrschaftsstrukturen mit
geringen gesellschaftlichen
emanzipationsmöglichkeiten noch weiter
erhöht aber das ist noch nicht alles
selbst wenn es den Kontinent gelingt der
Erwachsenen afrikanischen Bevölkerung
Perspektiven Inhalt des Kontinents zu
bieten wird der Einfluss auf den Rest
der Welt und vor allem die Bedeutung der
Migration stark zunehmen das künftige
Tempo des Geburtenrückgangs in Afrika
ist die wichtigste Determinante für das
künftige Wachstum der gesamten
Weltbevölkerung und wird massive
Auswirkungen auf Afrika und den Rest der
Welt haben vor allem auf Europa denn
aufgrund der alternden stagnierenden
Bevölkerung werden bald viele
Arbeitsplätze in Europa nicht mehr
besetzt werden können zum Erhalt seines
Wohlstands benötigt aber alleine
Deutschland laut einiger Experten eine
Zuwanderung von 400.000 qualifizierten
Migranten pro Jahr 400.000 wirkt bei
denen der afrikanischen
Bevölkerungsexplosion zugrunde liegenden
Zahlen natürlich wie ein Kinkerlitzchen
es ist weniger als 100 des jährlichen
Bevölkerungswachstums auf dem
boomkontinent die Herausforderung für
Europa könnte also darlegen sich jenes
eine Prozent zu stoppen welches so gut
ausgebildet ist oder zumindest
ausgebildet werden kann das ist als
qualifizierte Ersatz dient für die auf
der einen Seite in Rente gehen und auf
der anderen Seite nie geborenen Europäer
das gleiche gilt nicht nur für die
Migrationspolitik sondern auch für
Handel Investitionen Zusammenarbeit
Sicherheit und jede Art des Engagements
der europäischen Mächte in Afrika denn
je nachdem welche geopolitischen
Strategie Europa hier wählt könnte
Afrika zu einem unbeherrschbaren RIS
werden oder zu einem essentiellen Joker
des alten Kontinents im Wettbewerb mit
Amerika und Asien und wisst ihr was es
ist gut möglich dass Afrika auf diese
Weise bis zum Mittel dieses Jahrhunderts
einen wesentlich höheren Stellenwert in
den Bereichen Politik Wirtschaft und
Kommunikation für die gesamte Welt
einnehmen wird die Fragen sind sind wir
bereit dafür wird es eine einfache
Anpassung geben welche Folgen wird
Afrikas Aufstieg für den Rest der Welt
haben und sollten die reicheren Länder
versuchen eine offenere und modernere
Kultur in Afrika zu fördern damit sind
zum Beispiel die Integration von Frauen
die Anerkennung sexueller Vielfalt und
die Integration von Minderheiten aller
Art gemeint nun meine Lieben Zuschauer
das sind die großen Fragen der Zukunft
die noch zu klären sind wahrscheinlich
weitaus größer als die des Sterbenden
Russland und es ebenfalls demografisch
perspektivlosen China wir werden Afrika
in nächster Zeit nachher noch wesentlich
mehr Raum einräumen damit ihr euch ein
viel besseres Bild von ihm und seine
Zukunft machen könnt also vergesst bitte
nicht das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen
und Haut jetzt in die Tasten bzw auf den
Touchscreen schreibt uns was ihr über
Afrika denkt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gib uns bitte ein Like das mit euren
Freunden und vergesst auch nicht uns
eine kleine Spende zukommen zu lassen
mit dem Hotel dieses Projekt weiter so
führen den PayPal Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]